for over 100 years
hertz has been one of the most
recognizable names in the car rental
business
nobody has more of what it takes to get
you into a new ltd or
other fine car faster
but just like their superstar
spokesperson hertz would eventually come
to a complete
halt the short version is
coronavirus hits nobody's traveling
and they went into bankruptcy the long
version is
they were as badly prepared for
something like this as a company could
possibly be
it's almost every step of the way if you
were to say here's what not to do
for a company it almost feels like hertz
did exactly that it's just sort of one
flame out after another one misstep
after another
did they not understand how fragile this
company was
this is the story of how a company
prioritized shareholders over stability
and paid the price once catastrophe hit
coincidentally the company that would
become hertz was started in the middle
of another pandemic
in 1918 during the spanish influenza
outbreak
a businessman named walter jacobs
started a car rental business
in chicago with just 12 ford model ts
six years later the company grew to 600
cars
that's when john hertz then head of the
yellow cab company
would be the first to acquire the
company and rename it to the hertz drive
yourself system
after that hertz's ownership would
exchange hands quite a lot
from companies like general motors rca
and eventually
ford but during this time the company
saw a ton of growth the rise of
hurts uh in in the 1930s 40s 50s and
beyond
coincides with the era of increased work
traveling plane traveling
across the world hertz for example in
the early days it's able
to put one of its car lots at a chicago
airport so that's really helpful for
them
they move into this area where people
are going to be getting off of planes
and immediately want to rent a car to
drive to the hotel drive to their
business meeting and they're also able
to expand internationally
as well it really kind of became the
name in rental cars they really were the
first company to grow
big time doing this and they were very
popular with business customers so it
was seen as
aspirational brand for the guy getting
off the plane in his business sue with a
briefcase and hopping
into a car after he left the hertz count
i know it's a commodity business but
it's an iconic brand in the 1970s hertz
would look to advertise their speed of
service
and in order to do this they turned to a
professional athlete
who at the time embodied speed they're
giving him the chance and there he goes
o.j simpson has broken what seemed to be
an insurmountable barrier
at the time oj was an american hero
he was this great former football player
he was an actor
he was in some of the naked gun movies
nordberg hiya buddy
doc says i should be on my beat and as
good as new of the week people
absolutely love the guy who's kind of
got him at
the peak of his popularity others claim
to be fast but nobody has more to do it
faster
more pros to execute the toughest
performance standards hertz's
relationship with oj lasted from 1975 to
the mid-90s
but while the company would continue to
advertise their speed and efficiency
they would have new competition
enterprise a privately owned car rental
company
no more for their locations within
cities began expanding
into airports the whole hertz oj
connection
much like oj's life had this ignominious
end where uh the same year
that he was in the highway chase in this
white ford bronco
trying to evade the police and figure
out what he's going to do while he's
being chased in connection with the
death of nicole brown simpson
hertz also lost their top position uh
for for market share
in the us to enterprise so oj is no
longer this american hero
hurts is no longer the rental king and
it all kind of happens all at once and
and the downside for the company sort of
in earnest started right there
hertz may have lost the crown to
enterprise but by the mid-2000s
it was still bringing in tidy profits
for their parent company
ford ford was a company in trouble to
please its shareholders
it really wanted to focus in on its core
business which is of course
cars and so then you get forward selling
hurts to uh this private equity group
in 2005 the company would again change
hands to two private equity firms and
merrill lynch
co's buyout unit for about 15 billion
dollars
but losing ford as an owner had a big
impact on a core part of hertz's
business
where they got their vehicles they
basically churn automobiles they buy
cars
they rent them for some period of time
three months six months they make money
off of that
and then they hope to sell them for more
than
the resale value is in the market while
owned by ford
hertz would receive excess cars from his
parent company at a considerable
discount
many of these cars were known as program
cars where the manufacturer would agree
to buy back the car
at a certain rate of depreciation but
once they were no longer part of the
company
ford would often demand a higher price
for each vehicle
we were then forced to buy cars under
what was called
our own risk and that completely
changed the nature of fleet management
and the profit model
in the rental car industry this is
marianne keller she's an automotive
industry analyst and a former board
member for dollar thrifty
another car rental company that will
become important a little later on in
hertz's story
suddenly you really had to buy cars
carefully even to the color of the car
because you were really looking at not
just what you paid for the car
but what you were going to realize on
that car when it came out of service
the new private equity firm would also
kick off another ultimately fatal trend
at hertz
taking on debt the hertz transaction was
valued at 15 billion
but only 5.6 billion of that was paid in
cash the rest was paid by saddling hertz
up with debt
a trend that over the next decade and a
half would continue
one of the first things this private
equity group did
was take out a one billion dollar
dividend
and what that means is that they're able
to juice the returns they're able to pay
the shareholders and make it look like
they're more profits coming from hertz
make it a more viable
investment and it also allows them to
take on debt to do
more mergers and acquisitions to
navigate the company under this new
private equity ownership
hertz hired mark frazor to be the new
ceo
he's a pretty charismatic guy he was an
acquirer he was a negotiator he's a bit
of a character
he's also a deal guy fresor would go on
to have many successful years managing
hurts
including through the financial crisis
where hertz's stock would fall as low as
five dollars and 35 cents a share
before recovering to a high point of
over one hundred dollars a share
under for zora the stock price went up
during fasora's time because
of uh what what honestly we would call
over-promising
and essentially under-delivering but the
under-deliverance side the market found
out
later at the time it was just big
promises that the market believed
so he's very very focused on the
financials of the company because this
is what the shareholders care about
but mark for sora over his tenure of
hurts
makes a lot of mistakes there was
significant under
investment in the business and what we
mean by that is
that there was uh under investment in
the fleet
usually car rental companies will
refresh their fleet
uh almost every year and in mark
fosura's time
there was a year or two where they just
delayed refreshing their fleet
and what that did was that it lowered
the depreciation rate
in their p l which means that they were
over earning
in order to hit certain wall street
targets
such accounting practices would prompt
the sec to file complaints against hertz
and for zora
because the first year that you own a
car that's when you see the biggest
depreciation
and that depreciation that lowered value
in the car
you have to put that into your
financials as a cost
so it looks bad so instead of buying a
bunch of new cars he just
keeps the cars for longer so he doesn't
have that cost
the sec complaint against him also said
that he had asked some of his employees
to make money
appear when it looked like his
financials would miss
estimates for the various earnings hertz
and frazor would eventually settle with
the sec without admitting or denying any
wrongdoing
hertz declined comment from the story
and ferzora didn't return a request for
comment
a spokesperson for the former ceo said
previously that hertz's 2015 earning
restatements
have no bearing on the company's current
financial situation
and that first didn't direct any
improper accounting
or engage in any wrongdoing but the
decision to keep cars in the fleet
longer
did have an effect on its core customers
given the fact that hertz was the
dominant player in the corporate
travel market that was a huge
risk because you don't put a traveling
executive in a car with 50 000 miles on
it that squeaks
and smells you just don't and that's
what he did
the other thing that happened during
fasora was they moved the headquarters
from new jersey to florida and 85
of the staff the corporate staff didn't
show up meaning that they didn't move
with the company they had to re-hire
a lot of people hurts would find itself
carrying a lot of debt at this point
and a large portion of that coming from
its acquisition of the car rental brand
dollar thrifty now he wanted to buy
dollar thrifty
for most of the time that i was director
it started when
we had financial troubles in 2007-8
when there was a collapse in the used
car market there was collapse in the
economy
but negotiations didn't go well for for
zoro
it was chaos it was chaos
he had an opportunity to buy the company
at i think 54 dollars a share
we had been telling him that unless he
would increase the price he would not
buy it
he refused to listen to us hertz's
initial offer was rejected
and it kicked off a bidding war with
avis rent-a-car at the same time
dollar thrifty was able to successfully
navigate the recession
helping drive up its own price we knew
that we were the last
bite at the apple we knew that we were
running
as profitably as anybody in the business
he could have had the company for
something like i think
dollars a share and he eventually paid
87.50
we were very profitable very profitable
ultimately hertz would spend 2.6 billion
dollars on the acquisition
however it would quickly also run into
costly issues with integration
they had a really hard time integrating
the two companies things like they had
two different computer systems they
couldn't get the computer systems to
talk to each other
if you're doing a buyout of a company if
you're merging two companies this is
a very simple thing it usually isn't a
big headache but in this case it was
according to two people familiar with
the matter the merger that was supposed
to save hertz 100 million a year
ended up costing them 70 million in the
first year
and in 2014 the company would find
itself with 16
billion dollars worth of debt and what
what bothered me obviously was the fact
that that we were being blamed for
what was likely to happen in terms of
their earnings
and so i spoke to a friend of mine who
had contacts in the icon organization
and i said you think we should have
dinner with him and just raise this
subject with him
carl icahn is very well known as this
activist investor
so when he likes a company he'll come in
and
change it for the better and make their
stock price rise and that's how he makes
his money when he does
things like this carl icahn has
purchased
roughly an eight percent 8.48 percent
stake
in hertz carl icahn pops up with a
filing saying he's taking a large stake
and seeking to make changes at the
company so there's a lot going on there
this is a classic acquisition for icon
it's a company that has a great brand
it's well known
but kind of falling on hard times and
and he thinks he can come in
and and fix it up he uh essentially
forced for sora out
hertz ceo and chairman mark fosura
is stepping down from the company
rather than hire the former dollar
thrifty ceo scott thompson to run the
company
icon went with john take an ex-ceo of
united airlines
[ __ ] definitely inherited a company in a
mess
he has to deal with the sec
accusations against hertz he has to deal
with integrating the two companies
and part of what he tried to do was to
update the fleet because again the
strategy of hertz had been
to let some of these cars get old hertz
would find new
even more creative ways to take on debt
often leasing cars through a subsidiary
company
as asset-backed securities but hertz
would also end up buying cheaper sedans
rather than more popular suvs and their
customers noticed
by 2017 jonteg would retire and new ceo
catherine marinello would inherit 13.5
billion in
debt when marino takes over she has a
lot of problems to deal with she's got
this fleet of cars that people don't
want and she's got an old reservation
system that wasn't working well
so she spends a lot of money in a very
short amount of time to fix that system
and to upgrade the fleet of cars there
and offer people what they really want
she is doing the right things she's
helping to reduce some of the debt she's
getting customers
back to hertz the cars are starting to
look better
but there's a question of could she ever
have
fixed hurts in the state it was in or
did it just require
more time but hertz never got that time
the deadly
coronavirus officially hitting the u.s
as the world grapples with the deadly
outbreak people have grown anxious about
being in crowds
or traveling in confined spaces like
airplanes
so the pandemic hits and all the rental
car companies have
these lots at airports and on
main drags all over the country just
packed with cars
this is a big problem in the rental car
business you just can't get rid of
vehicles really quickly because we have
nobody running the cars
so money isn't coming in and then you
have to go to these bondholders who want
to be paid 100
in full so that gets them in a place
where they eventually have to declare
bankruptcy
because they just didn't have enough
cash on hand to pay back the people
who lent them all that debt hertz's
chapter 11 petition would show that the
company would have over 24 billion
dollars in debt
and only a billion of cash on hand
catherine marinello would resign as ceo
a week before filing bankruptcy and carl
icahn
would eventually sell his entire stock
in the company losing an estimated 1.6
billion dollars
carl's got a lot of money he's a
legitimate billionaire but even for him
that was a catastrophic
loss it does seem like hertz can survive
this maybe it'll be a much
smaller company when it does survive
this maybe the structure of hurts and
the way its
debt looks and the people who own hertz
will look very different but again
remember there aren't that many
car rental agencies so it still has that
brand recognition
i think that hurts could have been
turned around with different management
management that was really interested in
building
a solid business and getting rid of some
of that corporate debt that they had
because that made them more vulnerable
than anybody else
you know is astonishing that's the
achilles heel
if you look at what fursura did and what
icon did they did very different things
to the company but the common thread
with both of them is
they wanted really good quarterly
results fast
there is some i think sort of sense of
irony
that they take on this marketing
approach that's just running as fast as
they can and by the end
hertz has a ton of baggage and and tried
to grow
really fast through some tactics that
didn't end up serving it well